hey guys it's max today i am super
excited to check out
this little device that's in here which
is probably
the best most needed accessory for the
new
m1 max i ordered this about three weeks
ago so we finally
just got it in and this is owc's
thunderbolt 4 and usb 4
hub now yes apple doesn't advertise that
these machines have thunderbolt 4 but
they do there's only one limitation
stopping him from advertising that
and i think thunderbolt and the
connectivity is actually the weakest
part
of the new m1 max now yes on the macbook
air and the macbook pro the base models
always had two thunderbolt ports
but the mac mini had four previously and
the option for 10 gigabit ethernet
but now it doesn't we literally only
have two thunderbolt
ports here now what a lot of people
don't know and what owc figured out
is that there are still two controllers
for thunderbolt
so you can actually spread these out and
what this hub here does
is it'll actually take one of those
thunderbolt ports and they'll
make it into three separate ports plus a
usb
now that is fantastic for people like
myself where if you have a display and a
server connected
you're out of luck and when you try to
connect a high-speed ssd drive
you can't you're extremely limited so
not only are we going to test out
how much bandwidth we get with these
ssds and if we have any performance
loss through the thunderbolt and the usb
port we're also going to be connecting
it to my 6k display my qnap server and a
high speed drive
to see how well it does and this could
be a game changer for those of you guys
that bought an m1 mac let's go ahead and
pop this thing
open and the box is surprisingly heavy
and
the actual hub itself is pretty dang
heavy and solid as well it's made out of
aluminum over here
and then one really cool thing is that
the usb port up front it's not a
standard five gigabit per second like
apple gives you
on a lot of their macs it's a 10 gigabit
per second
port so that's twice the speed and then
this front thunderbolt port is where you
connect your computer
it's kind of weird that it's on the
front so let's spin this thing around
and there we go on the back we have our
power input and then
we have three thunderbolt 4 outputs
which is great we even have some locks
here if you need to
lock something and so it doesn't
accidentally disconnect taking a deeper
look in the box
we have our thunderbolt 4 cable that is
included
a little bit of paperwork and then we
have this
massive power brick and it does seem
like you need to use this
especially if you want to get power if
you're connecting a laptop for example
to this hub it can actually charge it at
the same time which is great
but i want to go ahead and connect it
without this 110 watt brick and see
if we can use it without it let's go
ahead and plug it in and even though i
am testing it with an
m1 mac this actually can work with the
new windows laptops that also have
thunderbolt 4.
i am not seeing any light at the front
here so i'm guessing
that it is not working just off of the
thunderbolt 4
bus let's go ahead and plug in one of
these
drives just to make sure and no it
is not working that is unfortunate
because it would be cool to be able to
at least use a few
low-powered accessories if you're on the
go but it looks like that is not the
case so let me flip it onto this side
and i will go ahead and plug in the
power let's start our tests with the
slowest drive i have this is the samsung
t5 which is
extremely popular i'm gonna go ahead and
open up my blackmagic
disk speed test and it looks like we're
getting about 380
on the right and pretty much the same on
the read so just
under 380. now let's test it out through
our hub here wow okay this is very very
interesting now we're getting 400 on the
right just dipped under 400
and let's check out the read we're above
400 on the read
as well now this might seem extremely
odd how are we getting
faster speeds when you're going through
a hub
then connecting directly well there's a
very good explanation to this and we
talked about this
in our macbook pro m1 review and that's
because
with the controllers that are built into
the m1 a
regular 5 gigabit per second usb
actually slows down
compared to the intel max we saw across
the board
i did a ton of testing transfers are
slower just regular speed tests are
slower and that is a downside that not
really many people knew about
when you're connecting through a hub
like this owc it has its own controllers
and that is what changes thunderbolt
into usb and we end up getting faster
speeds and in some cases i got about a
hundred megabit per second faster
depending on the drive so this t5 is
just slightly faster so
that is really good news not only do we
have more ports for connecting our
external ssds
we get faster speeds as well and then
connecting this t5
through the usb a port that's on owc
also gives us actually just over 400
megabit per second
compared to about 380 directly to the
max so no loss there
now let's go ahead and step it up and
what i'm gonna do is i'm going to
connect my four terabyte thunderbolt
ssd we did a review on this thing it is
fantastic i'll link that review in the
video description
great for storage and video editing
let's go ahead and connect actually
first
without the hub this thing is extremely
fast so it looks like we're getting
about
830 or so on right using this
thunderbolt
external ssd in usb mode so it's
connecting
over 10 gigabit per second uh usb so we
have 786
and 695 so we're not hitting that
perfect thousand but you never really do
let's plug it into the thunderbolt 4 hub
and it looks like this time around we
have 581 on the right and about 550
read which makes it seem like it's
connecting over five gigabit per second
instead of 10 gigabit per second but
that is odd
so let me go ahead and swap this cable
and see maybe it's the cable or maybe
this owc
isn't going to give you 10 gigabit per
second through those ports which it
should so this cable is actually labeled
10 gigabit per second
where the other one wasn't let's plug it
into that same exact port here
all right wow okay look at that speed
difference now we're at 1170 right
in 1606 read so all i did there was i
swapped
the cable and these speeds are actually
faster
than your standard usb c 3.2
i don't know if this is because it's usb
4 and using usb
20 gigabit per second or something but
the speeds are absolutely
incredible so you want to make sure that
you have the right cable get one that is
specifically
labeled 10 gigabit per second and now
let's go ahead and throw in
this thunderbolt cable this is what it's
actually designed to use
and let's go ahead and start out
plugging in to our mac
of course we only have two ports here
which is the main reason for this
is to give you more ports but let's
check out the speeds and bam
we are almost at 2000 right
and as far as read we are at 1700
and now plugged into the owc we're
getting
just above 1100 on their right so that
is a pretty noticeable difference in
performance and as far as the read we
get 17.77 so
slightly higher now i'm not sure why
this is
so i went ahead and i swapped my four
terabyte
for the custom ssd that we built and we
showed you guys how to build
in a video and look at that we're
getting at 1893
right about 1900 and for the read we're
getting over 2300 here
so this might just be a limitation with
this drive
and maybe the thunderbolt thunderbolt 4
connection because
this one is performing very very well
basically the same or actually slightly
faster
than when i connect it directly to my m1
mac
here i get 1825 and 22.72
and now i want to push this owc
thunderbolt 4 hub
to its limits i'm going to connect it to
the m1 mac and my 6k display
but i want to say this very interesting
that owc decided to give us
three thunderbolt 4 ports from one
single port that means if you have one
of these
instead of getting two ports or four
ports that you had with your previous
one you get up to six
thunderbolt ports and on top of that two
additional usb
ports that run at twice the speed of the
ones back here
just from a single thunderbolt 4
controller so let's go ahead and grab
this and move over to my desk all right
so we're at my desk here and i've been
using the m1 mac mini it has been
working great and i'm pretty much ready
to replace the beast that's behind me
and make a good amount of money back
since it has been working
so well for my needs the only issue is
not having enough ports so right now i
have pretty much
all of the ports on the back maxed out i
have my 6k display
i have my qnap central nas server
plugged in which i need
and then i have one usb accessory and
this ultra fast ssd but has four
terabytes of space i have to connect
over
standard usb which really slows it down
and i can't plug
anything else into the system so let's
go ahead and run this speed test
as you guys could see i'm getting about
340 megabytes per second
and as far as my central server let's go
ahead and test that and this should be
full speed because i am plugged in
directly through that port
and i'm curious if i'm going to get slow
downs
when i'm not connected directly let's go
ahead and unplug my accessories and we
will
plug in our owc thunderbolt 4 hub
and now let's go ahead and plug
everything into our hub
and plug in the hub perfect our qnap is
showing up
right away so it looks like we're
getting slightly slower on the right
speed but our qnap does fluctuate i'll
let it run a couple times
read speed is looking to be the same so
if we do have a loss
it looks like it might be about a
hundred megabyte per second
roughly around there on the right but
our read speed looks to be
basically identical which is fantastic
let's go and switch back over to that
four terabyte
and remember in the past i was running
this at about 340 megabyte per second
because i didn't have the proper
connections available now i am getting
1583 right which it seems like it was
even better than before with the macbook
an
1827 read very
very good performance here yeah it was
actually roughly about 1100 with my
macbook pro
awesome speeds so we went from about 340
megabyte per second when i have to use
my external ssd
to about 1580 and 1855
much faster speeds and what i typically
do is i transfer from my server to the
ssd if i need to work at home or on the
go
and back and forth that makes a dramatic
difference in performance
and not only that the server performance
stayed about the same
and i now have an extra usb port on the
back of my m1
mac mini i have another usb that's twice
as fast
on the owc thunderbolt 4 port and i have
one more thunderbolt 4 port over here
so much more connectivity and much
faster speeds now i want to do one final
test
i'm going to go ahead and unplug my pro
display xdr
and let's go ahead and plug it into our
owc
hub now i want to test this out just in
case you're somebody that has one of
those lg
5k displays or you have a 6k display and
bam
it is actually turning on and you want
to use two of these
the thunderbolt 4 hubs to get six
thunderbolt 4 ports and then two
additional usbs
from your m1 mac mini looks like it is
working just fine
we are still running at full 6k
resolution
we still have all of our options for hdr
video editing everything is working
perfectly it didn't scale back the bit
depth of the display or the resolution
like it could have
and let me go ahead and run this test
once again
all right so this is the four terabyte
ssd and we're still getting top-notch
performance maybe even a little bit
better than before
with the display plugged in and our
thunderbolt
ssd and our thunderbolt server i'll go
ahead and flip
back to that one bam it is now actually
performing exactly the same
as it did when it was directly plugged
in
to the m1 mac maybe even a little bit
faster actually
wow that is amazing so not only am i
getting the same exact performance
with my display plugged into it the
server plugged into actually
uh pretty good maybe even a little bit
better and with my ssd
i'm going from 340 up to 15 and 1900
megabytes per second
massive difference i now have two extra
usb ports available
and i have an extra thunderbolt 3
available on top of all of this
which i could connect one more of these
hubs so
that actually works better than i
expected
and it's 150 bucks it's not like a
massive dock that gives you
10 15 ports half of which you don't
really need and it costs 300 or 350
dollars
the price is pretty good as well so if
you're somebody that bought a m1 macbook
pro
macbook air and you need a few extra
ports especially if you want to do a
desktop setup
or if you want to use this powerhouse as
a full-fledged
desktop this is going to be a must-have
accessory so we're going to go ahead and
link it down below
and if you want more info on this ssd or
the custom one that is actually running
even faster
we'll have these links right over there
thank you guys for watching has been max
and i'll catch you in the next video